so
one of the magical things that uh
perhaps makes him
this earth quite unique is that
it's home to conscious beings so you
mentioned consciousness
perhaps as a small aside
because we didn't really get specific to
what how we might
do the alignment like you said it's just
a really important research problem but
yeah
do you think engineering consciousness
into ai systems is
is uh a possibility it's something that
we might to one day do or is there
something
fundamental to consciousness that is uh
is there something about consciousness
that is fundamental to
humans and humans only i think it's
possible
i think both consciousness and
intelligence
are information processing certain types
of information
processing and that fundamentally
it doesn't matter whether the
information is processed by carbon atoms
in
neurons and brains or by silicon atoms
and
so on in our technology some people
disagree
this is what i think is this physicist
that i i
and that consciousness is the same kind
of
you said consciousness is information
processing so meaning
you know i i think you had a quote of
something like
it's information uh
knowing itself that kind of thing i
think consciousness is yeah is
the way information feels when it's
being processed what's
we don't know exactly what those complex
ways are it's clear that
most of the information processing in
our brains does not create an experience
we're not
even aware of it right like for example
um
you're not aware of your heartbeat
regulation right now even though it's
clearly being done by your body
right it's just kind of doing its own
thing when you go jogging
you there's a lot of complicated stuff
about how you put your foot down
and we know it's hard that's why robots
used to fall over so much but you're
mostly unaware about it your brain just
your ceo
consciousness module just sends an email
hey you know i'm going to keep drawing
along this path
the rest is on autopilot right yes so
most of it is not conscious but somehow
there are some of the information
processing which is
we don't know what what exactly
i i think this is a science problem that
i hope one day
will have some equation for or something
so we can be able to build a
consciousness detector and say yeah here
there is some consciousness here there's
not
oh don't boil that lobster because it's
feeling pain or
it's okay because it's not feeling pain
right now we treat this as sort of just
metaphysics
but it would be very useful in emergency
rooms to know if a patient
has locked in syndrome and is conscious
or if they are
actually just out and in the future if
you build a very very intelligent helper
robot to take care of you you know
i think you'd like to know if you should
feel guilty about shutting it down
or or if it's just like a zombie going
through the motions like a
fancy tape recorder right and and
once we can make progress on the science
of consciousness and
figure out what is conscious and what
isn't
then um we
assuming we want to create positive
experiences
and not suffering we'll probably choose
to build
some machines that are deliberately
unconscious that do
cr you know incredibly boring repetitive
jobs in a
iron mine somewhere or whatever and
maybe we'll
choose to create helper robots for the
elderly that are conscious so
so that people don't just feel creeped
out that the you know the robot is just
faking it
when it acts like it's sad or hot like i
said elderly i think everybody gets
pretty deeply lonely in this world
yeah and uh so there's a place i think
for everybody to have a connection with
conscious beings whether they're human
or otherwise but i know for sure that i
would
if i had a robot if i was going to
develop any kind of personal
emotional connection with it i would be
very creeped out if i knew it an
intellectual level that the whole thing
was just the fraud
now today you can buy a little talking
doll
for a kid which will say things and the
little child will often think that this
is actually conscious
yes and even real secrets to it that
then go on the internet and
with all sorts of creepy repercussions
you know
i would not want to be just hacked and
tricked
like this if i was going to be
developing real emotional connections
with
the robot i would want to know that this
is actually real
it's acting conscious acting happy
because it actually feels it and i
i think this is not sci-fi i think it's
possible to measure to come up with
tools and make after we understand the
science of consciousness
you're saying is we'll be able to come
up with tools that can measure
consciousness
and definitively say like this thing is
experiencing
the things it says it's experiencing
kind of by definition if it is a
physical phenomena
information processing that and we know
that some information processing is
conscious and some isn't well then there
is something there to be discovered with
methods of science
giulia tononi has stuck his neck out the
farthest and written down some equations
for a theory maybe that's right maybe
it's wrong we certainly don't know
but i i applaud that kind of efforts to
sort of take this
say this say this is not just something
that philosophers can have
beer and muse about but something we can
measure we can study
and coming being that back to us i think
what we would probably
choose to do as i said is if we cannot
figure this out
choose to make to be quite mindful about
what sort of consciousness if any
we put in in different machines that we
have we um
and certainly not we wouldn't want to
make them you should not
be making much machines that suffer
without us even knowing it right
and if if at any point someone decides
to upload themselves
like ray kurzweil wants to do i don't
know if you've had him on your show
we agree but then covet happens so we're
waiting it out a little bit you know
suppose he uploads himself into this
robo-ray and it talks like him
and acts like him and laughs like him
and before he powers off his biological
body
he would probably be pretty disturbed if
he realized that there's no one home
this robot is not having any subjective
experience
right if we reply if humanity gets
replaced by
by uh raw by machine descendants which
do all these cool things and build
spaceships and
go to intergalactic rock concerts and it
turned out
turns out that they are all unconscious
just going through the motions wouldn't
that be like the ultimate
robo zombie apocalypse right just a play
for empty benches
you